I always wondered when you were on those
videos was there like did you have some
goal in mind or you're just like I just
got asked to this weird thing I'll just
[__] do it or did you always want to
kind of get a following I never wanted
to do YouTube okay uh I think I said
that a lot I want to stream I want to be
a streamer well you were right I was
we can get into that later yeah
relax anyway
um
overly Progressive losers
there's a lot more to it yeah I know I
know I know I know but obviously I won't
say it on camera but yeah
me money like so you know [__] them
um so no they're all right having a
crack but yeah I want to be a streamer
and um that was like where I guess that
it lines up more with kind of the MMO
kind of sphere well yeah I loved games
and I was I still played heaps of games
and I remember watching like criparian
if you know who that is yep I watched
his Hearthstone right yeah and like I
because I watched him back in double a
day when I was having that boy so I was
like I just want to be a [__]
streamer like I'm great at these games I
could do better if I was like committed
I'd do anything for views yeah and then
I did that and then I started streaming
and then I kind of realized I didn't
like playing video games on stream
anymore and then I was like oh do I roll
and then right I I have a memory of
clicking on one of your streams in the
early days and it said zero viewers or I
said one but you were still narrating
like hey guys
I know I know I know but it's just like
it's funny to like think about that as a
very cute as a moment in time compared
to like now
most streams have like two views and
there are people just not talking
because no one's here so I'm not going
to right yeah oh so yeah you didn't get
What It Takes yeah yeah yeah exactly and
yeah I was doing I was basically doing
what we're doing on cold one so she's
getting drunk every night and like
playing Mario Kart and people I don't
know for some reason people love a
really drunk guy playing Mario Kart oh
yeah so that was like the first thing
and then I played some wow and I played
some other games and then I started I
then they brought out IRL and then
people like figured out there was an
absolute effect it was scuffed as yeah I
mean it's still kind of it's a little
bit but it's got a lot better yeah but I
was like okay so you're telling me I can
get paid
to take my phone out in public be a
nuisance and get drunk and people like
yeah I'll donate to see that I was like
[__] say less say less I mean yeah
that first wave of IRL content was um
well it was it was something it was
definitely weird there hasn't been
anything like it since because it's like
you guys are the same but with like
videos and streaming every time you do
something sort of innovating because
that's what it was at the time it was
like something new yeah you have to one
up yourself each time yeah everything so
that but some people went down the wrong
path me being one of them I know a
couple other mates that went down the
wrong Park they're like well I mean the
IRL in general at that time was kind of
all about drinking and squatting yeah
swatting and then you know trying to
pick up girls or whatever yeah it was a
really weird time uh it's cleaned up a
lot luckily yeah I think so I'm someone
who's not so in touch with like the
street okay yeah this is a whole can you
break down what this era is for me
someone who doesn't know I mean you
pretty know better than me
it was essentially an era where people
were like loved observing other people's
life through a camera it was just like
big brother 2.0 right but like it was
always degenerative but it had to be
degenerate like it had to be or else it
wasn't even one of the track the train
wreck yeah yeah they wanted to watch the
train to see something [__] happen and
to pay for donations they're just
blasting out into a public space
did like an RV trip and I was on one of
them and it's just a [__] train wreck
they like find people on the streets
like not on the streets but they find
like [__] people on the internet and
they're like oh let's just bring this
train wreck of a person with us on this
RV because you know it's going to go
south you know it's going to be content
yeah it's not morally right but they're
like but money you know so right yeah
it's like it's like a big brother but
without like the whole vetting process
yeah
just bring the [__] crazy
because it was such a new thing there
was no rules for it so you could get
away with doing stupid [__] like that
but now there's obviously hard rules on
each platform you can't do it anymore
but people are still trying to capture
that old essence of it Sam Hyde's doing
um uh the fish tank a fish tank that's
the same thing it's got a bunch of live
cameras in the house 24 7 the other day
it was just some guy jerking off on the
couch like yeah that is definitely like
early [__] twitch days yeah is this
kind of getting like a comeback from
kick because I've seen like articles
every now and again I don't know I think
it's kind of like revital I think the a
lot of those like IRL streamers from
back in that period yeah
you know as a result banned off twitch
now kind of like recess because cake I
feel like at least right now it's kind
of like just the wild west yeah it has
to be because it's a new platform they
don't want to put all these but rules in
place yeah I think one of the main
problems though is that when you have
like content like that it has to be
viewer funded yeah because you can't
rely on Brands right yeah if you're
funded we're talking about way less
money well that's why twitch started
like pulling the plugins yeah you're not
making us more money than we'd make from
writing an end video out on the website
yeah like what was that clip of that
streamer in Japan who was just like
making a nuisance of himself the guy
lived in Japan for eight years
old
what's his name I can't remember what
his name is yeah that's his username
yeah but yeah he was just he was on it
it was like a clip of him on a train
because you have like Texas I did an IRL
stream in Japan but I wasn't [__] I
didn't do text-to-speech in Japan
because I know that that is [__] up
I'm in a foreign I did IRL streams had a
lot of fun there but yeah you can do
text-to-speech donations on the shoulder
yeah but he had no filters on it so it
was playing like all this scuff like
Skrillex yeah yeah yeah yeah just the
thing that blew my mind is that you've
got an altercation and then he'd been
living there for eight years and did not
say a single yes speak [__] English
like the best part was like the the
suspenders was like speak [__]
English and then the Japanese guy was
like speak [__] Japanese
looked up and the Japanese guy had like
perfect English
he said that in English yeah I was like
hang on why couldn't the Japanese guys
speak better English than you
you're pathetic existence to do stuff
like that it's like you just you know
you're just like a sad Lively wannabe
listen bro I was like one week away from
becoming that so you know come on let
him grind yeah
how many okay how many people at the
same time who went down that path would
have had like turned it around like like
0.1 percent no
I didn't turn it around I just gonna
band at a perfect time
I'm getting banned kind of like helped
though kind of may help you figure out a
better Direction I think it was a sign
from God
[Music]
yeah I only help you out I mean yeah it
was just like a point in my life where I
was like okay like I moved to Melbourne
after that and um I had some other stuff
I was doing and then
met Scott
um who does cool shirts he's like the
cool shirts guy and he like helped
direct our videos and everything like
that and then he was like oh let's do a
podcast it's [__] easy yeah and I was
like yeah I mean why not so we did a
podcast and then Max did one with me and
Max was like oh we're just a full-time
thing and then covert happened like oh
no more podcasts and then
which again was another like perfect
thing because that was the only reason
we stopped doing them really and then
started focusing on all the content That
was supposed to be like the filler which
is now the main the main content right
you looked at cold ones you would be
like this is like that's their main
stuff but originally it was like it's I
mean there's only so much as a podcast
as we know as well that you can
clickbait but there's only so many views
you can get on like a one hour two hour
video yeah those 10 minute or 20 minute
easy to digest videos with like really
crazy [__] happening it's way easier to
reach a bigger audience but obviously
it's it I mean it's a different product
right so yeah it's a totally different
kind of content so how did the idea of
cold ones like come about was it like
Scott's idea or was it I mean Scott yeah
essentially was like oh I got this video
idea where I really want to do because
he want to do a video where we went on
five run commission shirts and then yeah
we did that one and then the next video
idea was yours we were like oh the five
of it short videos let's order a bunch
of like shitty drinking games off wish
yeah and then we did that and then those
two videos did so well like we're like
what the [__] are we doing podcasts
McDonald's bongs or something and then
didn't wish tell us or that there was a
surge in sales yeah
we want to sponsor you yeah or something
like that because there was a wish House
in La I don't know if you guys ever
remember that yeah it was a tick tock
thing like once again Google wish house
what am I do
that
in L.A they did like a wish house so
they'll sponsoring YouTubers who wish
and it was a little bit a little it was
a little after a video and then I got a
contact with them and I was like yeah
you see this yeah and I was like oh hey
uh can you guys sponsor us because they
started sponsoring a few people I don't
think they've done any more they never
did it with us in the end it's the most
generic I think I said something stupid
right
um and they're like oh we really liked
your video because of that like your our
McDonald's bong had a really big surge
apparently all the drop shippers were
making like new wish things I like the
McDonald's bongs on a wish and
everything do you think a YouTube is a
keeping wish alive
yeah because I feel like every YouTuber
I know does watch videos because they're
just so [__] funny because everything
on wash is so scared yeah that's the
[__] hole like
it's like on you don't know what you're
gonna get it's like [__] like mystery
package is the five of like stage still
going yeah five are still oh yeah well
five would try to if I would try to
clean up the website a lot I don't know
if you guys no we noticed yeah they
sponsored us two for one thing and then
a second one and they never pay us yeah
they they gave me uh me a budget one
time and I remember they were like no
you do what you want and then I I think
as I was going through the video they
were kind of like looking at what I was
ordering and they were getting a bit
nervous they were like hey um
well yeah it was had some we got paid
for the first one and he was like oh
maybe next time you can't do this and I
was like [__] you shut the [__] up I
think I literally said to him on the
call [__] you so okay but he didn't tell
me not to do another video so we did
another video with the referral link
never heard from them again
I didn't really care anyway obviously we
want to make stuff that's funny we're
just gonna use your website to like
sanitize the content just to get paid
like a little bit on time yeah they try
to Rebrand the whole website to be more
like professional like there's so many
scammers
they're all gonna get [__] replaced
by AI
anyways AI generated
yeah it's like it's only a matter of
time before AI takes over like YouTube
Every time I mean have you seen like the
uh Balenciaga memes I've been going on
yes I love them oh my God ironically I
love those but at the same time it
terrifies me because I'm like dream that
Trend where a YouTuber would just like
take Reddit comments and just read them
out and they would get like millions of
views we we know uh lives right next to
us next to us makes millions from it so
yes yes it's only a matter of time
before you can just AI like a [__]
well have you not like a lot of those
True Crime channels now
ai voices have you noticed this yeah
yeah I have not noticed that I think
Cameo will be replaced by AI like
eventually probably yeah yeah we did a
cameo video recently that the only good
thing about it is we get a video with it
which is a bit hard to do with AI but I
was like why don't we just [__] like
use AI to do these voice actors voices
because they're not sending videos with
us yeah yeah I think I think we're not
far off being able to put anything you
want into one all like encompassing tool
that can because there is there all the
tools do exist already that can you can
create the whole video everything yeah
there will eventually be a thing which
is just like an app
make this celebrity say this and then
that that whole business because you
don't need it celebrity yeah exactly
someone looks like Hank to say yes
and then these celebrities where that's
like their secondary
income because they've you know they
used to do a famous show but they're not
really getting paid any royalties now
yeah they live off this I think that's
just going to be slowly phased out and
replaced and they're gonna have to use
I've noticed that uh did a real job
instead of watching some channels that
have like get a real job like drink on a
podcast I get a real job